he recently did another video where he
broke down one of my property
developments and he basically said that
I was lying he said that my figures
didn't stack there were incorrect
figures and that made me decide to not
only defend myself but to take a little
bit of a deep dive into developer Samuel
Leeds has just finished a property
development project but the proper he's
saying just simply don't add up still I
don't know the exact area works out to
be 27k again showing your ignorance you
really don't know what you're talking
about the price that I gave of 330 Grand
included stamp Duty and included s tax
we then have the solicitor's fees of 14k
I don't know which solicitors you use
but if you're paying
£14,000 you probably need a new
solicitor or if you never actually paid
a solista before because maybe you don't
actually own any land